[Music]  most europeans already have easy access  to quality drinking water  even so the european union is updating  its legislation to make tap water even  safer  quality standards will be revised by  tightening limits for contaminants  and taking into account pollutants like  microplastics  the new rules also call on member states  to further improve access to drinking  water by installing water fountains in  public places  um  the revised drinking water directive is  also a chance for the eu to make  progress towards its climate goals  drinking tap water is good for the  environment and good for your wallet  the new rules aim to reduce consumption  of bottled water  which will help to cut back on plastic  waste and save eu households more than  600 million euros a year  europeans should trust that their water  is safe to drink  consumers will be able to get up-to-date  information about the quality of their  drinking water  on their invoice or a smartphone app  you